pftot monday edition
this is the host pft live program in
which we talk about either something we
didn't get to
during pfc live or something we would
like to talk about
in more detail and chris you impressed
me today
uh because i i failed
to connect the dots and i pride myself
on connecting all dots
when there is an intriguing story like
the aaron rodgers
being potentially supplanted by jordan
love the idea
that if the packers had an owner a
real owner a traditional owner one
person
who calls the shots that that owner
would have said to brian guticunes the
packers gm
what in the hell are you doing when the
proposal was made to trade up
give up a fourth round pick to move up
four spots and get jordan love at a time
when aaron rodgers is still
in the meat of a big money contract it's
a brilliant observation
i feel bad that i didn't think of it
congratulations
and let's talk about that some more i
mean i'm fascinated by
how that could have played out and would
have played out it's another reason
why the packers look there's good and
there's bad
you can have a meddling owner that
screws everything up but sometimes
it's good to have a meddling owner who
keeps people from doing something they
shouldn't do
yes you know i think that's what good
leadership does
you know they can kind of just throw
their two cents in there every now and
then and go
hey it just seems to me just from the
outside you know looking in or
the 10 000 feet above type view that we
should go in this direction
and you know in this type of
conversation with the quarterback
conversation i think this is where
owners come into play
more than not uh you know they see the
value in franchise type quarterbacks
they do
and you know you can just go through the
test of time and look at special
relationships between
owners and franchise type quarterbacks
you know it's
it's tried and true no matter where you
look at it
whether you look at you know elway in
bowlin
right or dan marino and wayne heisinga
down in
miami all those years of course peyton
manning and irsay
mr kraft and tom brady you know there's
they realize the value that these guys
have to their organization
and how relevant they keep their
organization and the money that flows in
through them
plus the confidence the team gets
because these guys are in their locker
room
so that to me is where the owner comes
in a lot of the times and goes oh wait
wait wait wait wait
what brian guten goose i'm you know i'm
sorry but man
we got a quarterback right now that's
just left the like
you know edge of the prime of his career
here this doesn't makes i don't want to
do this i don't want to confuse things i
don't want to do this and throw
our you know organization into turmoil
which it is now in green bay right now
and they don't have that so that that to
me is where an odor comes in and they
lack that
in green bay i mean here's the first
thing that an owner would have said to
brian gouda kuntz when he proposed at
some point
the idea of trading up to get jordan
love
brian you just came to me 20 months ago
and made the case for giving aaron
rodgers
57.5 million dollars in exchange for
signing his name to the bottom of a
four-year extension
we have this guy under contract for four
more
years we've been with this guy for 15
years
now is not the time to get wobbly in our
relationship with aaron rodgers
now is not the time to have misgivings
about
whether or not he's being a little bit
of a jerk
we've known that this is who he is
from 2008 at the latest
when he became the starting quarterback
and you take that with
the the the good you take the you take
the whatever that is i mean look it's
human nature
sometimes guys are sensitive sometimes
they're prickly sometimes they can be
hard to deal with
as long as they're great players who
cares so now we're gonna stir that pot
up we're gonna make things worse with
this guy we're gonna antagonize him
when we've got him under contract for
four more years we've already made our
commitment to aaron rodgers
we almost got to the super bowl last
year what in the hell are you thinking
no you are not permitted to trade up and
draft jordan love that and
you know what maybe some owners would
have said okay
but i think plenty of owners would have
said you're just not doing that
well yeah and i think it's one of those
things too once an owner calls a gm's
bluff or has the conversation
and you make the gm have to say these
things out loud
all of a sudden it might not sound as
good out loud as it was when it was
stirring inside your brain where you're
gonna go whoa
wait am i really gonna put my name to
this and like
stake my claim here you know so i do i
think this would have been a much more
talked about type of issue within the
organization if the owner was there
instead guten koos has all the power he
wants and
doesn't really have to involve the head
coach or any of that
and i think you and i are hearing the
same rumors that it doesn't sound like
matt lafleur had any idea
or was clamoring for jordan love in this
draft pick
i think this is a total you know front
office pick all the way
you know i'll say this too mike just to
further the conversation
you know i can't remember uh i read it
over the weekend i read so much stuff
and
i'm pretty sure i read it you know on on
pft but just where guten kuz kind of
explained
this is how he was brought up in the
business right this is how ron wolf
or ted thompson i can't remember which
one he said had kind of taught him to
like think for the future
and all that and i'm i'm for that i
get that thinking for the future is part
of the gm's job
but times have changed a little bit they
have
you know you don't have to think of the
future when you're quarterback's 35 or
36 anymore
no not in the year 2020 you know aaron
rodgers has still got four or five
at least good years left in him here to
where he falls off the wagon and you
still want to start thinking about that
so i think they jumped the shark a
little bit in the
oh we're worried about the future type
process
let alone the optics of how they dug
themselves into this corner of
trading up for a guy not drafting
any receivers at all during the rest of
the draft
all of those things where i think an
owner would have talked sense into him
one i think the owner would have said
let's not take the quarterback in the
first round i think that's what he would
have said
i think he would have been like look
we're like you said we're really close
but two i think the other thing an owner
would have done
is if the gm did take the quarterback he
would have been like all right now we
got to make it up to our quarterback and
give them the
a stud receiver in the second or third
round and it just was like none of those
conversations happened and uh
i'm still in disbelief about the draft
in green bay
when if i'm the owner of the team and
and whatever team it would be anybody
who would be a fan of that team should
be very happy i'm not but
if if the gm comes in and and starts
saying
we need to draft a quarterback in round
one because we need to be thinking in
the future
i go back to the fact that 20 months ago
we signed this guy why were we thinking
about the future then
we did a four-year extension with two
years left
why in the hell did we do it why did we
do it why didn't we do a two-year
extension
why in the hell have we given the guy so
far
chris through the 2019 season
81.9 million dollars they paid him 81.9
million
for those two extra years as part of
this extension
and the reason they gave him all that
money up front is to have
the ability to keep him for four more
years beyond it
you don't give the guy over 40
million per year nearly 41 million on
average
in 2018 and 2019 unless that is the down
payment
on having the rights to him four more
years into the future
that's what makes this so ludicrous and
that's what makes it
just from a business standpoint what the
hell are they thinking
are they thinking and you're right
you're right
jared would jerry jones have done gone
with this would jimmy haslam have gone
with this
would would robert craft have gone with
this i i
i just i have a hard time envisioning an
owner reconciling
the contract they gave aaron rodgers
with this idea
of right now with four years left of a
relationship with aaron rodgers
making the move to draft his potential
replacement
yeah well and mike to even get into it
even more
i think that's like you know crazy we
talk about the draft
to improve your team oh we have
needs here we need to fill it or you
know we need a little bit more
depth here overall you know again you've
said already this is a team that's in
the super bowl window
they have other needs on their roster
one of their biggest needs was not to
oh we need to start worrying about
replacing the best player on our team
that's to me the other insane thing
about it they addressed the need that's
like
four years down the road from now what
what do we addre
why are we addressing the mvp of our
team
why are we addressing that that's what i
would say
i mean why are we addressing the guy who
was
in the conversation for one of the best
players in the nfl last year
really really i did that's where i just
i'm like
the more time goes on the more like mad
sarcasm wants to come out of my mouth or
i just i just don't understand it
the more time that goes by the dumber i
think the draft was
i got one more angle for you okay one
guy that
one guy who has not been mentioned
in any of the conversations that i have
seen or been involved with
since jordan love was picked and since
the packers emerged from the 2020 draft
with no receivers and that's team ceo
mark murphy who is the closest thing to
an owner
that the packers have and he has gotten
more involved this was post ted thompson
they did a redistribution they hired
brian gouda kunst
but mark murphy took over the direct
reporting relationship from the head
coach it's more
of a of a two towers now approach with
murphy in charge of everyone
murphy had to be on board with this
chris
and it makes me wonder whether or not
murphy has reached his lifetime
saturation level with aaron rodgers
where 15 years of it
is just enough and maybe look i i doubt
that gouda kudz did this
without getting mark murphy's blessing
and i'm speculating here
yeah murphy understands understands
the contract that they signed aaron
rodgers to a couple of years ago
but is at the point where he just he
just can't do it anymore
he just he's he's ready to move on he
saw what happened with aaron rodgers
and with with mike mccarthy and now he's
seeing some early signs of it now
between good accounts and the floor and
rogers and and we just we have to
empower our coach
and our gm we can't have this much power
in the hands
of a quarterback and it's only going to
get worse not better i don't know i'm
just trying to
i'm trying to glean whatever murphy's
role would have been
and why he would have wanted to do this
and it doesn't make sense
i'm trying to paint all this in the best
light possible for mark murphy and it
makes no sense
even when i try to do that i don't know
why they chose to agitate the guy
that they have given 82 million dollars
to over the last two seasons
for the benefit of keeping him for four
more years now that's trashed i'm
telling you chris
as we talked about during the show today
i think it's one more year
and then they're going to take that
salary cap hit because it's a lower cap
hit
than what it would be to have him on the
team and they saved 22 million dollars
and they get better value for him after
2020 than they would if they wait until
after 2021 to trade him i think he's one
year
and he's going to be traded somewhere
whether it's the raiders whether it's
the 49ers whether it's any other
team other than the team in the nfc
north like they did
12 years ago with brett favre i think
he's going to be traded after this
season
i i don't think it's a crazy thought
mike i don't you know i mean
listen i think the whole thing is crazy
okay but at this point now i mean i
wouldn't be shy i wouldn't be shocked if
aaron rodgers goes out and throws for 35
touchdowns and five interceptions and
just goes
ah see you later portrayed me you got
jordan loved see ya i went out of here
i wouldn't be shocked i wouldn't be mad
at him if he did it you know
and look like mike i i got great respect
for mark murphy and goody i mean gosh
how much fun have we had with goody over
the years where you know i'm always like
yeah
go to you you're the man and this is
just one i just
i don't agree with i don't agree with
the approach at all
and to the fact of it just seemed like
the
season ended off in such a positive way
between leflore and aaron rodgers
you know even after the nfc championship
game it just seemed like aaron rodgers
was so upbeat and so
happy about how the year went and he was
so excited about the prospects of the
future with matt lefleur and all those
things
and that's been all upset now and you
know
i i think more than likely and i'm going
to try to make a few calls too
where it you know the more and more we
get down the road here it just doesn't
seem like matt leflore was
signed on for this he didn't want to do
this this was not his draft pick
so now you're gonna make yo your second
year head coach you just got things
going the right way with the quarterback
you're gonna have to deal he's got to
deal with this screw ball
and having to balance the quarterback
room and answer these questions every
day
so that's just to me as an overall
organization
it just was more bad than good to me
uh for at least now and into next year
and that ends up raising questions
potentially between lefleur
and gouda kunst and whether or not mark
murphy needs to maybe
clunk heads together like mo howard to
get them on the same page
so i i i still think that goodie coons
is
is trying to take some of the heat off
of leflore by taking the blame for what
happened
uh so so there is a chance to to repair
or at least manage that relationship
between rogers and the floor but
let's let's spin this forward before we
go because i was on 93-7 the fan in
pittsburgh on friday and they asked me
about
roger's next destination if he leaves
green bay and the first team i thought
of was the raiders
raiders first and steelers second if he
stays
two more years in green bay one more
year i think i take the steelers off the
list because roethlisberger will be in
pittsburgh two more seasons
but let's assume it's one year one year
with
rogers in green bay where does he get
traded to next year
my first pick would be the raiders
what's yours
oh that's a good one it certainly is i
mean
you know pittsburgh's interesting
conversation too the other one i thought
about
was you know if the jared sidham thing
did not work in no england
i mean we know the affection yeah we
know the affection bill belichick has
foreign rogers i mean
you know again people just got to go
back and watch like his his monday or
wednesday press conferences when green
bay plays new england and hear
belichick gush about aaron rodgers so
that's
one that jumps out to me mike i'm just
looking through here
just to look if there's anybody else
just because he kind of caught me off
guard if there's anybody else that jumps
out to me
but i think that you kind of hit the big
names there
you know i don't know if jacksonville
maybe right right about the cults from
philip rivers
to aaron rodgers while you continue to
wait
for that next peyton manning or andrew
luck to land in your lap
right you know and they they drafted the
jacob easton kid from washington who's
got some talent in his raw
and not the kind of guy yeah like like
you're saying like i don't think he's
ready to take over like two years from
now or anything like that
yeah i think that could be a possibility
if philip rivers
you know has a solid year but it's still
just not good enough
the colts i think are going to be one of
those teams that will go into a 21
2021 season and still go man our roster
is still good
we got a lot of young guys in a lot of
key places here
do we really want to do the draft the
quarterback kind of like
you know put on the training wheels type
of thing or do we want to go
with another veteran guy who we know is
playing at a higher level than philip
rivers that we just signed here
and aaron rodgers and go with it i
wouldn't be shocked i i don't think it's
a crazy thought at all
what if sam darnold just doesn't get to
where he needs to be this year what
about the jets is a possibility
just like just like the brett favre path
the example the exact same team
to which farv was traded is where rogers
could be traded
uh you know i again i think you know
with sam darnold being the number three
pick of the draft i i don't think
they're gonna be
wanting to give up on that experiment
quite yet
but you know just like we saw this year
with jimmy garoppolo and tom brady
i don't care who you are when aaron
rodgers comes on the market and you
start talking about him
if you're not a quarterback that's won a
lot of playoff games or maybe been to a
super bowl
you could be replaced by a guy like tom
brady or aaron rodgers so
it's not crazy and and i don't think
it's that crazy to think of san
francisco
if they were thinking about tom brady
this year why wouldn't they if they
didn't win the super bowl with jimmy
garoppolo next year not
dangle in the conversation of whoa we
can get aaron rodgers
maybe we should do that so i don't think
that's a crazy thought either maybe this
number 12 gets to go back home to the
bay area
uh unlike the other number 12 i didn't
get to go i would i wouldn't the bank
on the packers if i'm the packers i'm
not trading him there i'm getting him
out of the conference i'm definitely not
trading them to the 49ers
um one more team one more team yeah we
talked about this team during the show
today in the back up quarterback draft
you've got a guy who was an assistant in
minnesota
for the entirety of aaron rodgers career
as a starter kevin stefanski joined the
vikings in 2006 and was there through
2019
he has seen up close twice
a year and one time three times in a
year
what aaron rodgers can do if baker
mayfield
doesn't get it done this year if they're
on the fence about him and you're not
talking about i mean you could just tell
them hey you're sorry you're the backup
for the fourth year of your contract
we're not going to pick up your option
you go to be number two behind aaron
rodgers and tough deal with it
uh aaron rodgers of cleveland brown that
would be something
what i mean i might have to get a
a cleveland browns tattoo or something
if they had aaron rodgers
and odell beckham jr on the same team
wait a minute no that would be my
favorite team
wait a minute i think we're on to
something are you saying
that if the browns trade for aaron
rodgers next year you will get a
cleveland browns tattoo
they did employ the big effort at one
point even though it wasn't for very
long
they did you're right i would almost did
almost that we had the jersey
got the jersey with his name on the back
of it and then he went there and the the
big effort went there and bill belichick
had to tell him that
and i don't think belichick realized
this until my dad got in the building
but art model came down to tell
belichick like
hey we're broke and the money you
promised phil sims we can't pay him we
can only pay him the minimum i have no
money because that was the year before
they moved the ball to uh baltimore of
course but
uh uh i i would seriously think about it
oh my gosh aaron rodgers and obj
and cleveland that would be amazing
well uh plenty of things to look forward
to if it does implode for
rogers and the packers and we know he's
smart enough to have already pulled out
the chart of all the teams chris
and started circling the places where
maybe he would like to go next year
because it can happen
next year don't buy the idea that
they're forced to stay together for two
more years i think after this year it's
going to end
all right we are going to end on that
note chris great stuff as always again
congratulations on thinking of the
packers not having an owner angle i'm
still a little pissed off about that
i learned ben spend may the fourth
learning more star wars character
names uh yeah there will be a quiz
potentially tomorrow all right see you
buddy
see you man
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports